- [Recording] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Daniel] So I'm going to change gears a
little bit and talk a little bit more
about behavior and selective forces acting
on several larger behavioral packages but
I have to say I do so with a certain
degree of anxiety because, thanks to
Photoshop, because there's two reasons
really why this talk has given me enormous
attack of the nerves. One is that I am, as
you've already learned, this is a really
confusing topic and anybody who ventures
to say they understand how our genus arose
is probably self-delusional. But the other
problem is that I actually started my
career actually getting interested in
studying the origins of Homo. And so I
have some kind of psychological issues
that I have to work out and so I hope
you'll forgive me if I start off this
lecture a little bit autobiographical and
I'll tell you a little bit how I got
interested in this crazy problem, which is
that when I was a freshman in college I
actually started working on this fossil to
try to estimate its cranial capacity. And
I thought that was really cool and we'd
published a paper and, wow, that's what
I'm going to do for the rest of my life
and then because of that for my senior
honors thesis we did the first
probabilistic study to ask if Homo habilis
and this thing rudolfensis were different
and that was really fun. And then of
course the next question, which was really
the subject of my Master's thesis, was to
see if we can figure out the evolutionary
relationships among these things and my
conclusion was there's so much
convergence; what we call homoplasy, that
it was a completely impossible task and so
I gave up on all this sort of stuff and
got involved in working on other things
like the fossil record and doing
biomechanics and stuff like that. But all
along I've been really interested in the
origins of Homo and one problem that
continuously puzzled me is that basically
I'm a splitter, I can split species. I
generally prefer to do that rather than
being a lumper, but I'm convinced that the
species Homo erectus really is a bona fide
species and it's lasted a long time and
it's had an enormous range of variation.
It's actually more or less doubled its
brain size over the course of about 2
million years and there seems to be sort
of this gradual increase in brain size
regardless of what the errors might be for
some of those points. And furthermore as
we're going to learn a little bit later
on, there's also an enormous amount of
variation not just in brain size but also
on body size in the species. And as you'll
learn from Leslie Aiello who will be
talking later on and also from Herman
Ponzer who'll be talking later on, there's
an interesting energetic issue here
because big brains bigger bodies and
they're probably other two shifts going on
like in life history, that require extra
energy and these are some estimates that
Leslie Aiello and Kathy Kee published a
bunch of years ago, it's one of my
favorite papers. And they more or less
estimated that Australopithecus female
like Lucy, she would've needed about 1200
calories a day, more if she were
lactating, whereas a female Homo erectus
would need a good 50% more calories per
day and again that amounts to quite a
number of calories required if they are
lactating. And at the same time, more
energy is needed you also see that Homo
erectus has smaller teeth so this is tooth
size of Homo erectus compared to Homo
habilis and Australopithecus and at the
same time also these are estimates of bite
force from a paper we published a few
years ago showing that the genus Homo was
able to produce much lower bite forces
than those of Australopithecus. So
therefore if they're getting more energy
it's not from eating more food, it's
eating from more higher-quality food. So
this raises two interesting questions. So
one is how did early Homo, and I'm going
to focus primarily on Homo erectus because
I don't really know how to make sense of
the earlier stuff, how did they get more
energy and secondly what was the effect of
more energy on early Homo erectus
evolution? And again I'm going to focus on
Homo erectus. And so there a lot of
hypotheses out there people have been
thinking about this for a long time. One
idea is that it has to do with food
processing, better efficiency at long
distance locomotion, you might call that
tracking, I've been of course very
obsessed with the idea of running and its
importance in hunting, and I'll talk about
that in a second, origins of meat eating,
food sharing, extractive foraging, the
list goes on. And to me, when you actually
look at all these tasks and put them
together what they suggest is that
actually what we're looking at is the
origins of a way of life that still
exists, just barely, called hunting and
gathering. And to me hunting and gathering
is really an integrated system. There's no
one component to it, it's not just hunting
and gathering, although both of those are
important. So you have meat, is an
important component of the hunting and
gathering diet, either through hunting and
scavenging, there's also foraging but
importantly it's often extractive so
you're actually digging things up rather
than just plucking them off trees or
collecting honey or whatever, things that
take more effort. But you can't make the
system work without also, without tools
and food processing and I'll talk about
that in a second, and furthermore the
system also requires intense cooperation
in various ways, division of labor, food
sharing, and so on. So I would like to
suggest that actually much of what we
think about in terms of the origins of
Homo has to do with this hunting and
gathering system and that you can think
about it as a trend not as a moment in
time when, voila, the world's changed and
as a trend, a selective trend, that has a
lot to do with energy and that you have
selection for two major kinds of skills.
First of all, they're the cognitive/social
skills, the skills that require increased
intelligence or brains, that's very
important for being a hunter and gatherer,
but there also athletic skills, hunter
gatherers are athletes, they actually have
to go out and do work every day and use
their bodies in complex ways and a lot of
the athletic activities that hunter
gatherers do involve endurance athleticism
rather than power or speed athleticism.
And those in turn led to increased energy
availability which then permitted
selection, you might even say it released
selection, released constraints on
selection for bigger brains, etc, that
drove the system forward. Here's a more
formal version of the model, so you have
selection for better hunting and gathering
abilities, a combination of brain and
brawn, not just brains over brawn, this
leads to increased available energy and of
course that's going to be especially
important for mothers.
You can only do so much with energy, you
can either increase the use of energy and
reproduction or you can increase it in
maintenance and growth or somatic
investment and that will lead to not only
maybe population growth but also energy
that can grow bigger brains, grow bigger
bodies, have longer life histories, and
that indeed leads to selection for better
athletic capabilities and better cognitive
capabilities which then keep the system
going forward and so that you have what I
would call a SIR Classic Feedback Model.
Now in only 18 minutes, I don't have the
opportunity to go into great detail, so
I'm going to focus on just a few aspects
of this model and I'm going to focus in
particular on hunting and scavenging and
then briefly talk a little bit about food
processing. So I've been interested for
many years about the problem how it is
that early hominins hunted and scavenged.
So here we have Usain Bolt mythically
racing a cheetah. It would be no contest
because Usain Bolt is the fastest guy on
the planet but he can run about 10 meters
a second, can do so for about 10 or 20
seconds, pretty much any quadruped out
there in the Savanna can run twice as fast
as Bolt and can do so for about 4 or 5
minutes. So he would have no chance, being
either prey or for that matter escaping
from any predator. In addition hunting is
difficult and chancey, humans lack natural
defenses and also, until very recently, we
lacked any kind of technology. This is the
oldest known stone point, it's
controversially dated to 500,000 years ago
from southern Africa and actually really
stone points really don't appear commonly
in the archaeological records until about
300,000 years ago. So that means early
Homo, if it was hunting and scavenging,
did so basically with just a sharpened
wooden stick or some rocks to throw. And
then finally, if you're going to become a
carnivore, you also have to deal with
other carnivores and that's a very
dangerous guild to deal with. I wouldn't
like to do that, I certainly when these
things happen, I stay in the Jeep. I don't
get out of it. So we've, Dennis Bramble
and I, of the University of Utah, based on
earlier work done by Dave Carrier have
argued that one important factor that
helped early hominins become hunters,
after all it's kind of a weird thing to
think about bipedal primates becoming
hunters, is our incredible ability to run
long distances at relatively fast speeds,
endurance running. And I don't have time
now to go through this list of wonderful
features that we all have in our bodies
literally from our heads to our toes but
we have a wide range of adaptive features,
features that improve our performance and
our ability to run long distances even if
you don't run long distances, you have the
ability to do it. In fact, you're right
now sitting on one of those features, your
gluteus maximus especially enlarged in
humans. And we think there's good evidence
that it's an adaptation for long-distance
running. And some of these features of
course we can see in the fossil record
some of them we can't see, of course,
because they don't preserve. We also have
some of these features, and the features
I've listed with the exception of long
legs, I believe can really only make sense
in terms of their ability to improve in
performance and running and not walking.
So these are not just consequences of
walking a lot, these are features for
running. And also intriguingly, and again
I don't have the time to do this today, a
lot of these features, not all of them,
first appear in the genus Homo. Some of
them appear in australopiths, that's for
sure, some of them we can't see in early
Homo though we have some guesses about
them from footprints that are dated to the
same time period. But for the most part,
if you look at the package of features
that make human beings able to run
marathons or other sort of long-distance
events they more or less appear in the
genus Homo and I think that we can say
that with some degree of confidence. So
how have these been adapted? So one
hypothesis is that it may have been
important for the very earliest
meat-eating, is that we started off, or
our ancestors started off scavenging. This
is called power scavenging, where you
detect a scavenging opportunity and one
way to do it would be to observe vultures
in the distance and in fact there's some
really neat data from South Africa showing
that actually vultures do this. So
vultures follow other vultures, so why
couldn't hominins do this too? And if you
do this in the middle of the day when we
can run better than other animals, you
would, particularly other carnivores, you
might have an opportunity to get to these
carcasses before, say, the hyenas or other
competitors could've gotten there, so that
might've been an advantage. We think that
the really more important process that
maybe happened later because we have
evidence that running, that hominins are
hunting, they're actually hunting large
adult prime males by at least 2 million
years ago, is a motive of hunting that
still exists, it's kind of rare, called
persistence hunting. And it's been
documented all around the world in Africa
and the New World, and Asia, and Europe,
etc, but of course it's become less common
today because we have not only
supermarkets but also bow and arrow and
dogs and nets and things like that. But
here's how persistence hunting works. So
I've graphed here on the X-axis speed in
meters per second and in blue here I've
got the endurance running range for human
beings and here's our sprinting range and
here I've got the trot range for various
quadrupeds. So humans can run marathons,
for example, well above the trot/gallop
transition speed of dogs the same size as
humans well above ponies and actually good
human runners can run above the
trot/gallop transition speed of horses. So
we can run long distances at speeds that
make quadrupeds gallop. And importantly,
when we run, we grew cool primarily by
sweating, such as this woman at the
Westminster dog show, but where her dog
and this zebra, for example, that's being
chased by a film crew obviously, can't
sweat, they don't sweat but they cool down
by panting, short shallow breaths. And the
cool thing is that when animals gallop
they cease to be able to pant, that's
basically because their guts slam into
their diaphragm with each stride and so
that's a serious constraint. So if you go
on a hot date don't take your dog for a
really long run and force it to gallop,
you'll kill your dog. So that enables us
to do something call persistence hunting.
Again as I said, it happens in the heat so
people typically do it in the middle of
the day when it's really hot, they'll pick
really big animals, the bigger the animal
the better, because big things overheat
faster than small things, and they'll
chase that animal, force that animal to
gallop, course the animal will gallop
faster than the human can run, the animal
will hide in the bushes but then the human
chases it, attracts it, usually at a walk,
finds it again and then chases it again.
So there's this kind of dance. In fact,
it's called in South African by the
bushmen, sometimes the great dance, which
they go from the chase versus track, run
versus walk, and over the course of about
15 to 30 km, again only about half of that
spent running, they can drive animals such
as this kudu into a state of hypothermia,
where the animal's going to die anyway.
And according to the number of hunts that
have been followed by Louie Levenberg,
down in South Africa, about 75% of the
hunts that he's followed, these
persistence hunts, were actually
successful, which is a remarkable level
for hunting. Now of course hunting is not
all about running. There are many other
adaptations, which I think are very
important, for example we've done work in
my lab on throwing. Obviously you need to
walk long distances in order to run, you
have to carry food back, you have to carry
weapons or things to defend you, the
ability to lose heat is very important. I
would also argue there are important
cognitive adaptations which are important
for hunting. For example, you have to be
able to track an animal which is not a
trivial task. You have to have really good
spatial memory and mapping, you have to
have a good theory of mind. There's this
wonderful book by Louie Levenberg,
actually in which he goes through the
various kinds of cognitive tasks that are
necessary to do this kind of hunting. You
have to be a really good naturalist with
knowledge of the ecology. You have to have
sharing and division of labor and
communication, etc. So I'm not arguing
that hunting is the sole deal here. And
furthermore, I would also not make the
argument that these are features that only
were beneficial for hunting, obviously
some of these features would've been
important, for example, getting honey, for
digging underground storage organs and so
on. So there's a lot going on, I've just
been focusing on hunting. I don't want to
overstate my case here. But I would also
argue that again there's more. Again
there's a lot of systems here to talk
about and I just want to talk about one
more of them today because again we don't
have time to do everything and talk about
the importance of I would say is food
processing. So let's imagine you're a
hunter and you've come back from a long
day's hunt and maybe one of those 25% of
the time, maybe even more who knows, that
you came back empty-handed. So you've been
gone for much of the day chasing some kudu
and damn you didn't get it, you didn't get
a lot of food. You come back and you're
hungry and you need food. You don't want
to go into negative energy balance. Now
unfortunately, I would say 2 million years
ago cooking hasn't yet been invented. In
addition, if you try to eat the normal
kinds of food that foragers eat, you're
going to have to spend a lot of time doing
it. Food processing... Chimpanzees spend
about half their day eating. They fill
their bellies, wait for their bellies to
empty, fill their bellies again, wait for
their bellies to empty, do that, basically
that's what they do all day long. You
can't afford to spend all night long
eating, waiting for your belly to empty,
to fill it up again to go in the next day.
And then finally if I were to give you raw
meat to chew, which of course, doesn't
require that much time to chew, you'd
actually have a pretty horrible time doing
it. You should by the way check out this
video. This is a piece of goat that we
gave to somebody in our lab and after, raw
goat I should say, and after 40 chews you
can see these are the other particles, we
had the person spit it out, you can see
that after 40 chews this person was unable
to actually reduce this particle any
smaller. In fact, and you can also try
this experiment at home if you'd like to,
the point is, that human teeth are
dreadfully designed or adapted for chewing
raw meat. But there's a simple solution,
all you need to do it sort of simple
processing that wasn't invented back in
the Oldowan that might've been started 3.3
million years ago, you can cut your meat,
which of course people still do to today
and you could also pound your underground
storage organs and break them into smaller
pieces. So again I would argue that this
suggests there's some kind of feedback
group going on in the genus Homo. You've
got selection for better hunting/gathering
abilities that's not just brains, but also
brawn and I would argue that many of these
athletic capabilities have to do with
endurance, but not all of them, power is
important sometimes, and that we have,
again, this feedback loop giving us more
energy, allowing more investment, not only
reproduction but in bodies which then
improve capabilities that provide extra
energy which drive this loop forward. And
of course for a theory to be useful it has
to have some predictive power and I would
say that it helps us explain several
trends that we see in the genus Homo. So
one, for example, is the dispersal of
humans out of Africa. If you do some basic
models and I'm not going to go through the
math now, if you have early Homo
increasing its population size by 0.4% per
year, which is about average for many
hunter/gatherers today, and you keep group
size and population density about the same
as hunter/gatherers you can actually
account for the dispersal of hominins from
Nairobi all the way to Tbilisi in between
50,000 and 100,000 years. Secondly, I
would argue that all this increased energy
might've been just what was necessary for
that increase in brain size and also body
size that we've observed and already
discussed about in the genus Homo. It
also, I think explains an interesting
specimen Homo floresiensis because we've
talked about increased energy driving this
positive feedback loop in Homo, well what
happens to those poor descendants of maybe
Homo erectus that ended up on the Island
of Flores, then they're stuck there and
there's not much food and it seems that
there, selection drove them in reverse so
they went down to smaller bodies and their
brain sizes shrunk even more presumably as
adaptations to save energy. And then
finally I think also it helps us explain
why we have such a hard time not only
talking about the origins of the genus
Homo but also its next transition to
archaic Homo, another maybe not so well
kept secret, as we have a hard time
defining Homo heidelbergensis just as much
as we have defining Homo habilis or Homo
erectus. And this is an analysis I did a
few years ago but if you take this fossil
which is an early Homo erectus and blow it
up to this fossil and actually look at the
differences in size and shape, actually
hold size constant, basically Homo
heidelbergensis, this archaic Homo is a
version of Homo erectus that has
essentially a bigger brain, you can see
that from these arrows, and a relatively
larger face, which I would argue scales
with having a bigger body. So basically, I
would argue that archaic Homo is a Homo
erectus that's basically had its brain
blown up and its face and body blown up
and that's more or less what you get. And
there's plenty of evidence now that it's
maybe then an archaic Homo and I hope
Leslie Aiello will agree with me that it's
really in archaic Homo that we see this
slowdown in life history, this extended
period of childhood, because early Homo
erectus doesn't have that. And I would
venture to guess, but we don't have any
evidence, that if you found an archaic
Homo it would have lots of body fat, like
most of us today, but not like
chimpanzees. I don't mean excess body fat
I mean the thin humans are still fat
compared to most primates. So in short,
hunting and gathering, I would argue
favored selection for both brains and
brawn and in particular I would say
endurance athleticism and that more brains
and more brawn led to increased energy
availability which released constraints on
selection for yet more brains and brawn
and drove an interesting feedback loop.
And the ramifications of this are
particularly interesting in a world today
where we get all the energy we want from
the supermarket and no longer have to do
any endurance athleticism in order to get
it, but that's obviously another lecture.
Thank you.
♪ [music] ♪